today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza it's
uh it's exactly what it is man it's a
pizza he knew that gray block
18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on
the way to the beach grey block I mean
then
what's up you little grilled artichoke
hearts ooh a grilled artichoke heart
that sound like a very Halloweeny treat
you know maybe rack of lamb that sounds
like a Halloween treat dude a lot of
foods just sound like a Caesar salad
like they made salad out of Caesar head
to Brut a past the Thousand Island
happy Halloween let's get into this
[Music]
didn't pay the rent
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got poison ivy
I've got poison hi
[Music]
yeah
have outdone boost on y'all trying to
jerk each other round for one that's it
and here we are and it is All Hallows
Eve are almost Hallows Eve you know it's
almost Hallows Eve it's coming up
Halloween when you can take a candle
think about whe what you can do is you
can take a candle and put it into a
pumpkin and the pumpkin comes alive
unless it's something special you know
it's uh it's amazing something that you
would think doesn't even have the
ability to you know have reach come out
of it a pumpkin a pumpkin you can put
eyes in it in a mouth and a nose and put
light inside of it and suddenly it takes
on a whole new
[Music]
venture because not only does that
pumpkin have the ability now but then
that pumpkin can make some choices of
its own and I'm happy to be here today
with you happy Halloween this week and I
sell look you know I'm celebrating this
you know I've already taken my heart out
and put a raven in there so you know I'm
running on that Edgar Allan Poe I got
that cage I got that cage that um you
know I got that that caged Crow and
that's what I'm clucking around with
this week I love Halloween I love it
you know I love that you can just I mean
you could just kind of you can feel it
open you can feel the you know this is
the this is that one that one time you
over they leave the the gate to the
graveyard open and we can come and go as
we want and the spirits from yesteryear
can come back and visit us so you might
feel something on your shoulder what is
that a rain drop you know is that a
couple of raindrops just tapped me on
the shoulder is that uh um you know some
bird Duty that you know hit me you know
repeatedly a couple of different bird
duties that hit me know maybe that's a
skeleton just pet top tapping his three
fingers on your shoulder because he's
got a secret from the past to tell you
you got to keep your spirit open we got
to keep our spirits open man I want my
spirit to be open because you know that
there's look there's secrets flying
through the air year-round year-round
but we don't we don't pay attention but
this is that time of year you know el
Dia de los Muertos the Day of the Dead
when we stop and we listen is that the
breeze I don't think so
my great-great-great-great grandmother
bitching about something from a long
time ago
that's Halloween here people complain
from so long ago that's one of the gifts
of right now one of the things that can
happen you know when you can take
something that's not working or that's
not even capable you know it's kind of
like the autumn you know this time of
year I love the fall - because it's
refreshing you know it's kind of like a
schastie love you ride that shasta soda
you know when i was young we used to
have you know different people at
different sodas they had pepsi they had
orange Krush had a picture of an orange
circle slice on it what else did they
have Mountain Dew and then they had
Shasta and Shasta was I think this [ __ ]
was it maybe a dime I can you know I'm
saying you could eat you could have you
could drink one you could you know
[ __ ] throw one out on the interstate
you could do whatever you wanted with
them they weren't he it was he it was
like for ten cents you either got
something to drink or something to throw
that was really hard
you could play football you could you
know paint it brown and play football
with it we used to do that sometimes and
then sometimes somebody would get hit so
hard the King would bust and that was
just that one fumble and the whole game
was over because it was just a 12-ounce
can but yeah we you that Shasta was just
basically a very minimal soda and but
that's what this time of years but it
was refreshing Shasta was so refreshing
that's what I remember about it and you
pour that Shasta and your throat in him
but kind of you know it kind of burned
your throat and it had a flavor it was a
grass berry or butterscotch or some
crazed full of sometimes the flavors
were you're like is this a flavor really
menthol you're like I don't know if
that's supposed to be a soda but you
would drink it all that Shasta and
sometime you couldn't even it wasn't
even digging to have a flavor it would
just burn your throat so bad and then
you would just be so grateful that the
burn went away that you'd be like oh the
soda is good because finally the burn of
the soda would
go away from your throat you like ah
thank God and it left you with a feeling
of like you overcame something it was
really just like a 12-ounce count of um
of challenge and adversity and that was
shasta soda but i love that did this
time of years refreshing you know it's
the time of year where you could take a
you know things start to slow down a
little bit even in california california
you know in los angeles one of the
problems that we have here is and I know
I'm constantly naming many of them but
one of them
besides traffic and a lack of community
and I'm talking about in the city you
get out into the suburbs a man things
are a little bit more regular but you
get here in the city man it's just
there's a lot of greed and loneliness
let's overcome people and but one of the
things that I to me one of the things
that that this time of year allows is
for you to to start something new to
take a life you know even here it slows
down a little bit cuz the season starts
changed it gets a little colder here in
Los Angeles so suddenly you you know you
get a little like oh it makes you look
around for a second cuz you get so
caught up and being in the sunny days
here and I get so caught up in being in
the sunny days here that I don't know
the year just all runs together and
every day there's like some you know
there's a couple of vagrants running
around dressed up like Santa
you know pissing in a park and stuff
like that and you know hiding bottles of
urine and stuff from each other and
playing you know hide and go sip the
running around just drinking each
other's urine and that's in the park
right by my house dude duck duck piss
brother buns people out there playing
games dirty games of different urine and
some of them selling dirty urine and
clean urine in the park by me trying to
you know people trying to pass drug test
people trying to fail drug tests people
just trying to get their thirst quenched
you know there's a lot I mean if you put
your ear up to the wind at night in my
neighborhood you could hear you know a
lot of just dirty gallons being passed
between hands but but this time of year
even in Los Angeles the the
it gets a little windy and it gets a
little cool and the seasons come in and
you just kind of get a second to like
breathe I feel like and to look at
what's going on around you and and you
can take something old and you can put
up you could put a light in it you can
kind of you know see how something has
fared you for this past year you know
I've been doing this has this been good
you know I been eat you know I mean I
you know I've dated a girl you know
she'll wake up in the middle of night
and get a bunch of skittles and do you
know do skittles in the middle of the
night you know crawl back in in a bed
and she got a mouthful of those you know
those little rainbow of flavor crumbs
though you know then little you know
look like a little couple of rabbit
duties those you know rainbow rabbit
Duty hitters then sugar hitters and she
got a jaw full of them and she go back
to sleep with a mouth full of Skittles
and now she but and she could handle it
because women are organized when women
are can be very organized and now I'm
laying here on choke watch making sure
she don't choke all night but what I'm
saying is that this is the time of year
where you can take something oh but you
could if maybe you look at that have I
been putting skittles in my mouth and
going a bit maybe that's not serving me
anymore maybe it's time to let that go
and let that be a ghost or you could
take something like I've been thinking
about this but I haven't really been
doing it and now you could take action
and do that you know you know you could
find something that's a pumpkin it's
good it's nice it would make a nice kind
of veggie casserole but if you spend a
little more time with it and you hollow
it out and put some eyes in it and drawn
out on it and cut a little mouth into it
and you put a little bit of light in it
a little bit of time a little bit of
effort and now you got something that
you're gonna use to haunt the rest of
your year you got something that you've
taken that isn't it's not perfect yet
you know maybe you got some construction
paper sitting around on the table and a
little bit of tape and you've been
thinking ah you know I'm gonna make
I'm gonna make a origami lantern and you
but you haven't been but now's the time
take a little time slow things down put
some light into something put some light
into a family member put some light into
a friend you know and watch it and watch
it grow into something beautiful
that's gonna help keep you warm and keep
you excited some new adventure that's
gonna carry you one into these winter
months a little bit more that toon here
it was and that was Vampires Suck and
that's by Jean Bjork and you can find
that out there and eat there somewhere
and that's just some haunting music just
something to keep you tempted and
something to keep you twisted and just
remind you that this is a week to have
fun this is a week we need you if you
want men Halloween is a great time to
tickle somebody in tickling we should
enjoy tickling before they outlaw it you
know they got a lot of these snarky you
know angry people that just write
articles and stuff all day and most of
them are just on Twitter angry sad
they're probably gonna start outlawing
tickling say you they say you trying to
molest people's bones through their skin
[ __ ] I'm tickling somebody okay I'm not
doing whatever you're saying I'm
tickling alright
I'm bringing these uh I'm bringing these
um these phalanges and trying to get
them giggle Angie's out of somebody you
know I'm trying to play those ribs man
when I grew up actually they had a lady
in our neighborhood and she was a um rib
reader and she was a mystic and for
maybe 40 cents she'd breed your ribs you
know just run her fingers up along you
down up and down the sides of your ribs
for maybe about prob about six or seven
minutes breath and kind of tell you your
future pretty cool pretty cool that she
could do that you know and she also did
hair you know and her real name was Miss
bobbing on the weekend
you put a different sign outside and she
would do hair dude the haircuts from her
no joke no joke for dollars so you got
that four dollar chop man and it looked
like about maybe it was worth three
dollars
dude I would go there all the time I
left out of there I looked Amish you
know I look dumb I looked a couple times
I look like a a doll like a kind of like
a cheap doll you might get maybe in
Poland I looked like yeah sometimes I
didn't look like somebody to cut my hair
look like somebody just basically tied a
bunch of like scissors to their foot and
then just kicked me in the sides of the
head a couple times you know just like I
got that karate cut yeah suddenly I'm a
black belt and looking like [ __ ] but
dude something was fun about being young
and looking like [ __ ] man and when you
look like [ __ ] man you roll up into a
place dude you got nothing to prove
because nobody's expecting anything I
like that that's one thing that's a
costume I don't want to wear anymore as
expectations you know I'm gonna get rid
of these expectations in this fall I
wish you a happy Halloween man I just we
I was at the Orpheum I just got back
from Phoenix thank you to everybody that
came out it was crazy man this whole
weekend was crazy I was at the
confidence comedy festival in Phoenix
and I got to do two nights in a theater
you know I'm talking that John Wilkes
Booth country boy pop-pop that Lincoln
killer bro we were in a real theater and
dude it was just magical they say your
name you come out on stage and
everybody's excited you know y'all met a
young guy he came out with his aw with
his father they came to a show they had
a young a guy on his brother I met them
outside of the stage during we took a
picture some you know some lovely
students from ASU you know some nurses
beautiful beautiful group a lot of just
great people came out I met a betelgeuse
they had a man being a Beetlejuice out
there
man it just really warmed my heart dude
you know honestly when I really think
about it just warm my heart to like I
don't know I can't really explain it
like yeah I know I know you know when
and did the jokes and everything but I
just the people that come out I'm
noticing that are coming out to the
shows or I don't know it's like people
that I would just like to meet in real
life you know everybody everybody I meet
just seemed like just easy to talk to
understanding I don't know man it just
makes me feel really good you know and I
don't mean that in a selfish way like it
makes me like the going onstage part of
in doing the jokes and stuff that makes
me feel good but I'm starting to feel
like that's that's just like a that's
just like a bait for the fact that we're
able to get together you know that we're
able that were I feel like we are you
know what we're doing through hearing
even through this podcast is just
bringing good people together and I
don't feel like I'm responsible for that
but I feel like you know I'm just happy
to be part of that but I'm telling you
I'm telling not joking at these shows
people that are coming out man it's just
special people you know and I feel like
you know I feel like we're gonna be able
to do some good things in the world and
it's going to take some time but I
really feel like we're gonna be able to
do some good things in the world man a
man that makes me feel good and so I
want to say thank you you guys for
coming out and supporting you know the
laughter I think maybe that's what it is
maybe you know the laughter is kind of
like the you know part of the not bait
because bait feels like something that
you use to trick but maybe the laughter
is just it's like a little fire you know
and it gives us like a place to kind of
meet but I feel like in the future we
can do some really great things together
somehow and and I'm happy to be a part
of that and thank you guys coming out
dude it was crazy you walk out on the
stage and like people are and you can
all you can hear is you can hear people
well you can't
you can feel it a little bit you can't
see very far because they got light some
[ __ ] in the back shine a bright light
right in your [ __ ] eyes brah
it's kind of like cops when cops knock
on the door of your car dude that's
always the craziest man when the cop
knocks and you're trying to think like
man and the worst is when you hid your
your weed in the glovebox what a idiot
man you hid your weed in the only place
the cop is gonna ask you to open I did
it I've done that before
license and registration the second you
start to lean towards that glovebox
you're like [ __ ] I'm an idiot I hid my
Wie right there boom BAM dude a buddy of
mine one time hit his handed the cop the
registration and some weed man I do you
[ __ ] dumb bro like I'm done but you
are definitely definitely dumb but you
had a great time in Phoenix and and I'll
be back there actually in March tickets
are on sale yet but I do want to let you
guys know that I'm come back there for a
full weekend at stand-up live I had such
a great time and I can't not come back
and and that was it man I was up there
with Brendon shelves and Brian Collins
big Jay oakerson Ari Shaffir and I was
just honoured man and it being like a
big stage is cool because now it's like
you have like a playground you know I
felt like during the second shot told
this story that I that haven't been
telling very much about my mom and I
just felt I had like a big playground to
move around on remember like when you
would go to school and you would get
like if you say you were in third grade
in the next year you went to a different
school and you had that first recess on
your new playground and it was like dang
what's going on out here they had some
toys you know they had the monkey bars
they had the slide the slide was always
a piece of [ __ ] bruh honestly dude
especially in the south man they gave us
metal
slides basically here's a oven that you
can slide down if you want to do to some
days it was 97 degrees down there in our
town and the one toy out there you got
70 kids trying to play on a [ __ ] hot
slide so basically here's what would
happen you'd have one kid go down then
the other 69 kids are now suddenly
playing a game called EMTs emergency
medical technicians because they had
that one do bruh [ __ ] a little hot
legs Daniel you know he'd be at the top
and people be like Dan yo but you know
Daniel Bryan he makes his own choices
dude he makes his own choices and old
Daniel who had just recovered from the
burns from last year gonna give that
[ __ ] 96° slide a second chance
and man the second he hit the top of
that slide when he sat on it bro you
could hear the scream start and I mean
the type of scream that starts in your
toes and just reverberates up your
thighs through yo just your crotch area
I mean dude you'd see the weave that we
would shoot right out of his body the we
which though it was just too hot that we
would just boil this hmm like a steam
like somebody just made a batch of
chamomile in his bladder and just that
tea kettle just blew out that bladder
the we would just shoot right out of
them just like the Polar Express was
taking off out of his crash and then
that that scream would just reverberate
right you'd see it rattling through his
chest and it would just too steep just
steep right out of his mouth hurt as he
would hit the slide and his legs are
just roast
I mean just a couple damn just beef
Jerky's I'd do a busy laying on the
ground and all the other kids playing
EMT suddenly just cuz old [ __ ] hot
Daniel wants to try the slide again come
on tighten up tighten up man it's good
to be here I'm happy to be here you know
I was listening to some old episodes of
the podcast and I was trying to think if
duh and I know a lot of people don't
care they say just do the podcast but
you know I've just been feeling I think
I've been feeling so busy it's been hard
for me to feel more relaxed and more in
touch you know and I want this podcast
to be a place where you know I can share
what's going on in my life and you guys
can share what's going on with yours and
so I'm gonna try to work on that
personally over this holidays and just
get myself physically into a better
place where I'm feeling just you know
just managing my time better and less
exhausting and stuff like that so that's
a commitment that I want to make to you
guys as our listeners and I know some of
you guys are like hey man just you know
thanks for being here and thanks for
showing up and I appreciate you saying
that but I want to do better you know
you know because I know in that you know
if I'm listen to some old episodes and
sometimes it just I don't know they're
just there was points where it felt more
not more caring but just more like it
was just us you know like it was just
you and me so in some ways I want to be
able to try and you know I want to work
towards that and this is the time of
year to think about that and I'm glad
that I have some time now with the
holiday isn't going to see my nieces and
nephews tomorrow man I can't wait I'm
going down to Baton Rouge I'm gonna be
in New Orleans tomorrow night and then
I'm going to see my nieces and nephews
man and God has blessed me with so many
nieces and nephews man I really uh you
know it makes me so happy to see like
those children having fun you know I
mean I call my niece and nephews and
they're on the phone and they're just
having fun you know they're not fighting
like whenever people would call us at my
house we're always fighting man somebody
always scream and give them be
do somebody you get the phone if the
some I remember getting beat with foam
bra people beating each other with the
[ __ ] phone if they tell somebody hold
on
and then you hand the phone to somebody
in the neighbor beat you with it like
damn brah you know this [ __ ] is heated
out here and these Telus streets
it's Halloween time I'll be in Buffalo
also this weekend then I'm going to
Buffalo New York
and that'd be cool and get up there in
the winter see a little bit of the
wintertime maybe you know going some
hiking trails I don't know what's going
on up there in Buffalo you know let's
beef jerkey country that's buffalo
chicken wings you know they got them
little wings and I think honestly I
respect Buffalo but I think it's sad to
take a wing off a little bird like that
imagine seeing that little bird land
hand-done nut and he'd probably just you
know this little bird probably in the
first or second grade and he don't need
he got these little bitty ass wings you
know he probably still wear like
training uh you know special underwear
on kacie p.m. self in class and stuff
like that and Here Come these big
companies and they chopping the wings
off of them come on Buffalo what are
y'all doing and then they put the celery
right next to it make you feel better
about yourself because celery don't care
about dying
you know celery celery is that green
victim bruh it's that green willing
victim celery just say hey chop me down
cat daddy I'm ready for the Lord but
they you know they they they that celery
they just show that as a little
accoutrement but the real crazy part
they got these first and second grade
little chickens and they taking their
wings off of them just to put them in a
little bit of ranch how about this once
you make a can a little buffalo chicken
wing spray I spray a head it out on my
tongue get that feeling in that vibe you
know and to get those vibes of CW vibes
on my TZ and then I'm just you know a
little squirt or ranch in your mouth
and then I can sit there while I have
that and think about these beautiful
little chickens finally making it in the
third grade you know in getting report
guards and getting you know you know s
isn't positive scores on their little
report cards in their first and second
and third nine weeks and all of that so
just a thought man but I'll be up there
Brian I'll probably have some bug in on
them teriyaki hitters some buffalo
chicken wings a lot of great calls that
came in I will be in Buffalo the only
other place that I'm coming to be
there's some other places but the only
place that you guys don't know about
that I'm gonna be is um where else Oh
Lexington Kentucky December 7th and 8th
and those tickets are all are on sale
Buffalo and likes and the other places
for this year I believe are sold out
what else happened this weekend man oh I
got nervous dude you know one thing
sometimes like um you know I'm trying to
deal with like you know meeting more
people and stuff like that when I'm out
just you know running around and in the
bathroom I'm fine I got that nervousness
you know I got that nervousness and
nerves it's basically like dirty
electricity that hides in your body and
I get it when I'm at the urinal you know
in the urinal is just basically a
special hole that they made and they put
like a pretty thing over it and you just
urinate into it it's by the wall and I
get up there man and I noticed I was in
Phoenix you know I'm peeing at the urine
doing what I do you know letting God
just pull water out of my body through
the front of me and I couldn't go and
the two dudes that we all showed up at
the same law at the same time and then
they left they got finished you know
these fellows are all emptied out and
I'm still just standing there just
riding you know I mean this is like a
you know it's like a river rodeo I'm
trying to get that river I'm trying to
spark and I'm just basically pushing as
hard as I can just like squeeze like
pushing forward almost like you would to
try to do a duty but you doing it
towards the
for urine and I'm just pushing man I
can't get that you're in the fire I can
get that match to strike that flint to
steel I can't get it and then those
dudes finish the second guys so now I'm
still standing here and you can still
like the first dudes had already washed
our hands and they left you know now the
second dudes are white and I'm still
there brah
so now I'm not even peeing I'm just some
guy who's been holding his dick for
about two minutes and that's that's
crazier when you think about it you know
when you think about the fact that then
you're just some guy who's been holding
on to his penis for two minutes around
other men there's nothing wrong with it
but there's nothing right with it and so
it just you know that was something I
did you know just I was just got gun-shy
and I noticed that my nerves will land
right there in my crotch a lot of time
in my C Raj you know right down there by
my baby bird by that spicy frog and
that's what I'll notice and that started
happening me again so I'm a little bit
worried sometimes about how I'm dealing
with anxiety but I think a lot of that
is just I got to start taking some
better care of myself
and so I got into some physical fitness
you know because one thing is my mind
hasn't been doing a super great like
very you know I've just been I've been
in my head too much and so when you're
in your head then you got to get into
your body
because you know your energy is just
your energy your neck is that
mason-dixon and your energy you need to
keep it even and if you use that you
know sometime you got a union a little
and sometimes you got to Confederacy a
little because you wanted you wanted to
be even-steven you want to have both
parties just sitting right there along
that mason-dixon just playing handball
and doing Yatz look I did I wanted a
Yatz one time with nine dice so I'm not
saying I'm you know no Jesus Christ but
you tried only took me 70 rolls run did
a Yahtzee with nine dice broth all fours
player I'll see you in heaven see you in
heaven but I'm gonna start getting back
into some physical fitness because I
want I want my mason-dixon to be
you know to be a safe place for
everybody because otherwise my nerves
get all up above above and then all that
energy gets stuck and I'm frenetic in
the top and and that's all you know and
I want to I want to be even I want to be
even Steven
oh happy Halloween guys we have some
costumes that came in you'll be able to
see these on the YouTube I'm gonna look
through the pictures really quick I want
to thank the people that sent them in
first we have and I'm looking at them
right now for the first time and also if
you see our set we have a very spooky
set today and that's beautiful man I'll
say this man my mother always decorated
our house my mother always decorated our
house you know she my mother always did
good with holidays she always did good
with holidays man she would make sure
that on holidays you know him like
important events you know she did good
on those and she made all she always did
the decorations and stuff like that and
I you know I loved the fact that she did
that man that makes me feel really proud
of her for doing that cuz I bet it's
probably hard when you're a mom and you
get home sometimes or you know you
finally got that one day off and the one
thing you want to do is go get that box
out of the attic especially when you
don't even have a attic we just had a
box just tied up near the ceiling and we
would say that's the attic it's like
there's just some [ __ ] rope and tape
about a ceiling but you know covering a
box but that was our attic you know and
one of the toilets upstairs got leaked
out one time you know they had that
Brown ring forming around the base of it
and it started to kind of you know crap
you know the toilet will start to hide
in the floor a little bit if it gets if
the the wood or whatever it is the
linoleum gets to damp around it and you
know we have four kids by us so the
chance of hitting the toll and when you
urinate and with four children
I mean you shooting at about probably
22% you know what I'm saying my shooting
yeah you're probably about 22% so a lot
of that moisture in that body urine we
get into the wood around the tallit and
the toy
started to kind of you know fade into
the wood a little bit because if wood
couldn't hold it up because the wood was
getting all greased out from the
children urine because children you're
right you know you could run a go-cart
off a kids urine that stuff spicy that
stuff spicy that's got that kick kick in
it you know you put a drop in each
eyeball dog you could see Fabra children
urine super powerful in Native American
times you they would take children's
urine and they would die they would die
different like bird feathers and stuff
in it and wear them and put them right
in the crack of their bud and stuff
during like dances and parties and stuff
for good luck so the you know the
medical capabilities of children urine
priceless bro
children urine I mean if you have let me
think if you had about six gallons of
children urine and the cops show up
you're [ __ ] bro I'll tell you that so
it's okay to use it medicinally here and
there but don't go you know tapping your
little nephew to get it out of him stay
classy keep your life right with Christ
all right man um here's a custom costume
look them right now this first one is
Lucas and Sammy from Ann Arbor Michigan
submitted this one and he's dressed up
like a um like a cat or something
and he gots a drink with him so he
dressed up like a drinking cat you know
he's dressed like a uh and she's dressed
up like a little lady she's wearing red
stuff and he's got blood around his
mouth so he might have something
hepatitis C or something and she might
she looks like a nurse she looks like a
nurse at a picnic like a picnic nurse
and he looks like he got he's a Hep C
cat you know so he's he's hip he looks
kind of nice he'll he's hip and he's
helped so they are a nice group there
and that's Lucas and Sammy and but one
of them's a woman though but both of
them have men's names and that's okay
doesn't matter all right next up we got
Sean and Sebastian Hornbeck
and they dressed up I mean they look
like a couple they got green hair white
faces white shirt look like a couple of
Cher noble Italians bro
they're like a couple of uh you know a
couple waiters at an Italian restaurant
that mmm
that uh that also secretly want to be
Irish they got green hair and they got
lipstick on too
so they're thinking about doing
cross-dressing obviously and they might
be family one of them's real little and
looks like he's about seven years old
and one of them is bigger and looks like
he's about 27 so they're either friends
that probably shouldn't hang out because
it could be illegal I'm just guessing
man I'm not accusing you guys of
anything you know cuz I've you know I've
been around people I shouldn't be around
but if you see their picture and this is
Sean and Sebastian Hornbeck and Nate I
think they dressed up as a couple cher
noble Italians but beautiful they're and
then we got this do Brent rice and he
has speckled uh-oh have you seen that
commercial for the candy on the arm
television and the people eat the candy
and then it's all over their face and
they got acne they got that sugar at me
and that's what he has he's got that
face with the sugar at me and he looks
like he got maybe he could have been bit
by a gay guy or something as well
because my cousin last year got bit by a
gay Gulf Highland and everybody knows
that um all right let's look at another
one oh and that yeah that was Brent rice
this is Davy Jones and Rebecca Jones oh
this is I've seen this before he is the
man who painting they have a man on
television sometimes when you're you
know high or not even high just being
alive and you're flipping through
channels of television they have the you
see that guy on there and he's painting
and it looks like mr. Rogers his little
brother you know he's got big hair he's
got that fro he's that a little fro baby
you know like like he got spit like some
of his pubis you know was it like there
was a flood and his pubic hair climbed
up onto his head in order not to get wet
you know to take care of its family and
everything
so he looks like he got that flooded
body that pubis up top and then his
girlfriend is dressed as a painting and
this man you've seen him on television
you always have the old-fashioned little
paint it's like a little cardboard with
paint on it little chunks of paint
different colors that little uh you know
that little ROYGBIV handheld piece and
his wife looks like she has a stream and
stuff on her and you know she's a
painting canvas and that's nice Davy
Jones and Rebecca John beautiful all
right the last one we got a man in a
wheelchair or a fake man in a wheelchair
or an actual real man in a wheelchair I
can't tell
and another do-right him look like he
works at Bubba Gump shrimp company and
they got a man here he looks like he
sells weed or something this could be a
man or a woman or could be a child this
could be a teenager and he's in a
wheelchair he looks like one of those
guys that plays basketball on the
documentaries and he's got long hair so
he might be also a woman and he has on
let me see an American flag or something
and this dude man he looks like he works
at Bubba Gump he looked like a youth
pastor you know it looks like a man he
obviously is with the church you know
he's got on white shoes bright white too
like the kind that you ever meet a dude
who you know he's like 40 but he still
lives with his mom and he never moved
out and he never really finished he
don't he don't have any school
certificates at the house yeah boy you
know one of the lords you know one of
God's favorites you know what I'm saying
and he's beautiful guy and and he has um
and he his little buddy is in a little
wheel it's either a wheelchair it's just
um it could be like a handicap
wheelchair could it be a regular chair
that he put wheels on I can't really
tell but the guy didn't look like he has
legs either and no offense to anybody
that doesn't have legs and I'm making
fun of that the guy doesn't have legs in
this picture but they look like they
might have met it like a V a VFW or
something or outside of a McDonald's and
that's
Velasquez and his girl I'm sorry to read
that it is his girl it's cute and happy
Halloween and that's this is that time
of year when you can do whatever you
want well you could dress up like our
rapper and you can get out into the
world and you can live you can live you
can live man and that's really the gift
to is with this time of year just
reminds us we get to be alive go walk
through a graveyard and see if you don't
have some gifts you can't be feeling bad
about yourself in a graveyard you take a
test go walk through a graveyard if you
feel bad about yourself then that's on
you because you got a lot you got a lot
you got a lot of opportunity just with
this gift of life but maintain a child
man I'm just trying to stake a stay in
my own head we got some great calls
about Halloween and some different
things I want to thank the people that
sent the photos in and let me make fun
of you guys and roast your costumes and
think about you guys you know I like
seeing different people whether it's in
interaction you know pictures drawings
you know little dolls of other people I
like all of that voodoo dolls
well dioramas sometimes you do a diorama
and have some people in there and I like
to meet all-time all types of people I
want to let you know this right now that
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing data science mobile
photography creative writing you name it
they've got it remember those dreams
remember those things those little
pumpkins you wanted to put a candle in
go get that hitter you can do Facebook
ads for e-commerce you can do trap music
production you can do sketch you can
learn how to mix music you can do After
Effects and the basics of sourcing and
sales for entrepreneurs these are all a
few of the classes
that you can check out at Skillshare
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set or just start a
side hustle Skillshare comm is the place
to go and you can get two months of
skills chair for just 99 cents
that's right Skillshare is offering this
past weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access for over 20,000 classes
and it's just 99 cents so all the things
you think you'd want to go back to
school for and do this and do that try
it first on Skillshare see what you feel
see if you really have an inkling for it
and also you might be just looking
around and find an inkling for something
they a talent that you do want to learn
you know your dreams they're not that
far away these days and and by not that
far away I mean they're at Skillshare
comm slash Theo go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo to support this past weekend
and to start your two months now okay I
will be in Buffalo this weekend at
helium comedy club and and we got some
cool calls and stuff I want to get into
some of them here we go
homeward hey hope you're doing well man
this is Noah
hey Noah thank you for calling and Noah
that's a Ark name so dude I cannot I
mean I'm only gonna assume you're a boat
captain but cuz I can't imagine how do
you grow up and be a Noah and not drive
a boat
that's like saying that's like being
named bambi and not you know not getting
killed in a drive-by you know what I'm
saying like certain names the you know
the story has been written you know you
can't be named or Jess Simpson and not
you know get gruesome over there in
Brentwood with your old lady I mean a
certain names you can't do something and
not be it like you can't be named Carl
and not end up working over at that
sandwich house that they got onward
University Ohio University man thank you
for calling sir in Athens Ohio and man I
know you love Halloween
and we happen to have like the biggest
block party in the country for Halloween
at our school and I heard you talking
about there's a guy who called in who
lost his dad a couple years ago yes I
remember that I don't have his name
right here in front of me maybe I'll
give him a buzz this week he did call
and he called and lost his dad on
Halloween and this will be the second
anniversary of that homework and you
gave him the advice to maybe dress up as
his dad and go around you know maybe
visiting some old friends and you know
just like being his dad for a day you
know and I decided I'm going to do that
this year is my costume my dad was in
the Drug Enforcement Agency for 30 years
and he was busting some of the biggest
criminals in the country man he worked
his ass off
I lost him a year ago and I miss him so
much but I I'm sorry for your loss man I
bet he's really proud of you dude I can
hearing your voice uh that you sound
like a confident guy you know when you
sound like a guy and this is judgment
but you sound like a guy that has his
act together and I bet your dad always
heard that you know and I bet I bet he's
really really proud of you bro you know
to have a son that is um you know you
might not be a drug enforcement agent
but you sound like an enforcing type of
person a guy who's um you know he's
moving forward with his life
onward some of his little clothes left
behind I got a DEA eradication team
shirt on a DEA Ohio
a hat I got some aviator sunglasses I
got some camo pants and some boots and
man I didn't know if I'd be able to do
it because I thought it'd be like you
know emotionally difficult for me but
I'm excited man because I'm wearing his
clothes you know and I get to just like
kind of be him for a day I don't I'm not
being him for a day but I'm paying
respect to my dad and also having a cool
ass costume to wear and partying and
just have a good time yeah man I love
that dude thank you for this call
dismiss him you're making me think and
make me feel as I'm hearing this yeah
you know as you're saying that man you
got me excited now cuz it's like for a
night you get to be your dad you know
when you got some of his clothes man
that's such a nice gift you know we
don't think about those types of things
you know I never I never had anything of
my father's you know I never had
anything in my father's you know his
other children they took everything or
whatever you know I don't have anything
of his but one thing I remember a lot is
the smell of of his shirts you know I uh
you know when um because I was just so
young around my dad that a lot of the
things I don't have a lot of full
memories of us spending time as much as
it's like more of my senses you know I
remember a sound like he always had his
keys and change in his pocket and it
would always I kind of jiggle jingle
when he walked and he he whistled a lot
he liked to whistle but my dad would
born in 1910 that they didn't have a lot
of instruments or even sounds back then
I mean if you wanted to hear you know
different the sounds they had back then
the wind cannons
you know vultures rumors so I hear you
know so very limited sounds so he would
whistle because you know that when my
dad was growing up whistling was
probably one you know an Olympic sport
so when he would whistle a lot and I
would remember that so it's funny I'll
have certain senses but one of them is
the smell of his shirt you know my mom
and dad didn't sleep in the same room I
that was set up at night sometimes and
drink beer and I will walk through the
living room or walk in there at night
you know and uh and he would have me
come over by him and he would give me a
hug and I would smell like his shirt you
know and I love that home word I just
wanna say man thank you so much for that
advice
I love the podcast I love you you're
amazing thanks man I love you too bro
you know and even if we are not even gay
wearing just buddies and that's okay
man that's cool though dude you're gonna
be out and you know what I love about
this man now you got me thinking we're
doing this now we're doing Halloween
we're getting a Latino bro you know el
dia de los muertos they go and honor the
dead I went last year too and this is
one of the blessings of Los Angeles's
there's a lot there's a large Mexican
contingency here in fact a lot of the
history of California's is Latino
history outside of Hollywood Hollywood
steals a lot of the Thunder but the
Lightning is Latino here you know and
and they go to the graveyard some do and
it's I think it's an older tradition
probably and I'll have to ask someone
when we have someone on this Mexican and
and they go to the graveyard and spend
time with their family you know and
spend time with their deceased so this
is really novel I think man this is
interesting to be able to take your debt
put your dad's clothes on and go out and
about you know it's funny I was thinking
about that guy the other day who said
who had called about his dad passing
away and and I was like yeah maybe if
you dressed up as him you know if you
could get a mask made of your dad right
with the eyes so you can see out of it
and then it might be cool if you could
go as your dad you know get his clothes
put them on and then
and take on his thoughts you know like
what he was thinking about what he
enjoyed you know try to really get into
his mindset a little you know maybe walk
into the door that he walked into or sit
in a chair that he sat in or just think
about things more actually more just
think about things think about your
mother but from like his per you know
that this is your wife not in a dirty
way don't be thinking dirty things man
you know stay out of that part of your
dad's brain those are his thoughts those
are just between him and your mom you
creep you little worm just stay in the
other side the good side or you know the
legitimate side and
and think about just think about what he
thought about just yeah like to imagine
that sitting dressed as your father and
looking at people that he cared about
and what if you looked at a picture of
yourself that would be pretty wild
when that'd be cool man address I'll
pick your dad and look at a picture of
you
and then just be able to feel how much
love you probably had for you
you know imagine looking at
picture somebody that you care about
more than anything and then you would do
anything for and that you're so proud of
and I know that sounds kind of crazy but
I don't think it sounds that crazy you
know the Mount
majora was inside bro I musta lag tight
you know and I'm trying to get inside
and I think that would be super bro and
there's no way your dad's not gonna feel
that that's Halloween man that's dark
art and but boy you got
you got candles with you Gang Gang man
thank you for that call that's a
beautiful call making me think about
that and also just reference him back to
the man that called away a a week or so
ago all right let's take another call
hey Theo what's up it's Josh from
Buffalo just calling to let you know
that we're excited to see the Rat King
and the home of the chicken wing this
upcoming weekend
that's true this weekend is the king in
the wing I never thought about that man
that's that's nice you to reach out in
advance of me coming over there more and
also wanted to extend the invitation you
know me and all my buddies were a bunch
of musicians we're big fans were going
to be coming up to show Friday but
Thursday we're playing right down the
road at a place called the Tap House so
if you want to come on out maybe bring
the strap
we'll be there the whole curious crew if
not we'll see you Friday but uh check us
out man come hang out with the curious
crew Tap House on Chippewa if not we'll
see you at helium Saturday brother all
right we'll see you
awesome man and yes you were only
allowed to say we'll see a three times
in a call I'm just checking with you um
dude that's nice of you if I have the
energy if I got the vibe Thursday then
I'll get out there you know I'll try to
combine see I don't want to promise you
though um well I bring the strap out
into an alcoholic environment you know
where they got loud instruments and
stuff like that
the strap is that the strap is young the
strap you got to think of the strap it's
like a nine month old man that thing is
just sleeping through the night so I
don't know if I'm bringing net you know
sometime you got to keep the nice [ __ ]
at home sometimes even the oyster man it
hides its pearl when it goes out on the
tail and it comes back and picked that
[ __ ] up later but we'll see man and
thank you for the call
and no matter what I'll see you guys on
Friday and and I'll try to come through
on Thursday but no guarantees but I do
appreciate the invite 100% that's nice
you to welcome me into town a lot of a
lot of beautiful people up there in
upstate New York great place to get
tetanus shots and a uh and what else
Oh neck tattoos baby gang gang Rochester
till I die son brother wheeze let's take
another call right here hey Bo
so I'm fun to tell you about my 9 year
old nephew okay you got a 9 year old
nephew so do I so game on I know you
have nieces around the same age I saw
your one video but this kid has the
worst start to his Halloween weekend so
yesterday
Friday I don't even know what the [ __ ]
data does to be honest at you
he had doubleheader pepti his elderly
Chihuahua Sweet Pea had to get put down
cuz she was sick okay you got a 9 year
old with a Chihuahua though Ness is that
illegal you know what kind of 9 year old
you got him with a chihuahua that's the
part that's kind of got me a little bit
nervous for him that's a frenetic animal
Chihuahuas get scared that doorbell
activists you hit that doorbell those
[ __ ] go for 90 minutes you know
it's like watching a [ __ ] loud movie
and you can't get the volume turn off
but with that set rest and peace to that
little animal you know what Chihuahua
sometimes is just a [ __ ] it's like a
spicy slipper you know they're crazy
tour wild you know every year there's
probably there's like I heard of a Retta
article or heard an article that there's
like two 300 chihuahuas that died just
from you know just basic [ __ ] around the
house a book falls off a shelf and you
know takes it back out but let's hear
more and then out of the blue his guinea
pig named nugget got really sick too and
had to get put down on the same damn
thing
ooh yeah I'm sorry about that
I'm sorry your son lost to animals a
little while
Chihuahua which sounds I don't know
though 12 we didn't even have a name
that sounds to me like I'm not sure if
that's realistic that could be your
animal but little nugget that's another
story
you know and I'll say this for a little
nugget man I'll do a little prayer for
nugget right now because you know that G
pigs have a strong place in my heart G
pigs gerbils you know short rats all of
those animals you know nugget you know
you worm you're meant you weren't meant
for this world little nugget and God
wants you somewhere else maybe he wants
you out there in Asia or you know and uh
you know Vietnam or something like that
or in the future but God didn't need you
right here anymore little nugget and so
this your time this your time to get out
there and just you know chew away at the
cheese of reincarnation brah and maybe
you'll come back as a tall tall
beautiful nug not even a nugget more
like a chunk in another time or another
sphere and we wish you well young buck
and I hope that wherever you show up in
the world bruh that they got mad hoes
for you my man alright and big hearts as
well Gang Gang brah love you but that is
a worst weekend for a nine-year-old so I
have leave work early go take this
guinea pig to get put down well his mom
went to go get the Chihuahua at them and
he cried all last night about it and he
also has two other dogs that died this
year oh come on Lady look what's going
on here he's got two other dog what kind
of you know what kind of CHOP are you
running over there you know I'm not
accusing you guys of anything but it
sounds like you're picking sick animals
and then shoveling them off on little
Randal or whatever your son's name is I
mean what's going on
what kind of you know what kind of
halfway house for the for the halfway
living are you running over there you
got animals popping through there you
got little gerbils with spina bifida and
all of that popping through you know you
got Li you know you buying next thing
you know you got them a rabbit that has
a Hep C or you got you know you get them
a little seahorse with AIDS or something
you know and I'm sorry I'm not trying to
be crude to you but but this seems wild
doesn't it
you keep bringing these animals around
your boy and they keep perishing and now
you know yeah he's nine years old what's
next for him The Dude's lost [ __ ] 30
animals it's like you know it's like uh
it's like not Noah's Ark but like you
know little Randall's shitty raft and
all the animals that get on they drown
out because the raft gots bad ballast on
it so I'm not accusing or anything but I
will say this it's Halloween time so
this is a great time you know take your
son out maybe and let him visit the
spirits of the animals maybe get your
boy out there put a diaper on them or
something on the hold you know if I
don't know if people are doing diapers
at nine years old if they are getting
one of those lean diapers so that other
kids don't see it so now I laughing at
him and stuff get them a regular you
know baby you know a tight diaper one of
those lean ones and uh and get your boy
out there maybe you know draw pictures
of the animals on his body do some smoke
or some sage or something you know maybe
have one of the neighbors light up a
John or something in the distance
you know upwind of you and you'll catch
those vibes bro and let him visit those
animals that you guys are you know that
little law a little portal that you guys
have created over there and so the
nethersphere and I'm not trying to be
rude but you know I love you and I love
your son and I hope whenever he's you
know I hope you know he doesn't lose
another 60 animals by the time he's you
know 18 years old but at this rate mommy
you got to get a stethoscope or
something at the house and start
checking these [ __ ] primates that are
passing through because the animals that
are you know this is a one-way ticket to
the cemetery when they get picked up by
y'all it seems like but with that said
you know I love you and uh Gang Gang and
I hope to see you soon in the future
sometime let's take another call and
that is the worst weekend that is the
worst weekend and we'll put that in to
end of the contest yeah dude you know at
this rate that guy's gonna have Jesus
that guy's gonna be living in some kind
of dang I can't even imagine
I'll pray for that kid little Randal
y'all put little Randall in your praylis
homeward take another call I do my name
is Jacqueline take care of the podcast
thanks for calling Jack and thanks to
your fan ship and my problem is just
when my son would say extracurricular
life um with the ladies and so I've had
a girlfriend for a little bit now and
I'm 18 so you know we're kind of getting
frisky
oh you at 18 you can do adult sex and
that's normal and natural man and a
scientific there's nothing wrong with
that erection city bra
you know like running around with a bag
of clubs dog you got that pitching wedge
that Sam wedge bra you got just got that
regular dent you got it all at that age
man beautiful homeward hair we have sex
but I feel like I jerk off so much you
feel like it or you know you do
homeward half-sizes been a problem since
I was younger mum just jerked off so
much yes I hear you
or how about the paint today's holiday
but paddle the penguin I've never heard
of that breath unless you blowing them
ice cold splotches you know more but I
feel like it he had to type like mid
sense I'll just like go soft now I won't
be able to get it back up
it's like embarrassing I'll like make an
excuse I'll say I'm tired or something
you tired from tired from what do at 18
this is it man tired for you working in
a coal mine or something me can be tired
at 18 you got to have that virality bruh
you got to have that electric dick
that's what they're expecting anyway but
I appreciate you for sharing this man
let's hear more so you're feeling kind
of some desensitization it seems like
down there your nerves aren't really all
keyed out but it's just I don't know
what to do I tried to stop but it's just
like if I keep all callback to just late
at night or of all about myself I just
feed the geese you know feed the
geese never heard that dude let me and
I'll say this I'm if you've ever fed a
goose brother violent animals you try to
put your your wiener out near an ear a a
geat I guess one gate one geese that
thing will do that one thing will give
you a very fast sharp [ __ ] and that's
that's very very dangerous do not do
something like that so I can't really
tell what you're trying to get into here
what but if you're masturbating too much
yeah you're gonna be desensitized and
I'm saying you can uh if you beat a
guitar against the wall all day
then it's not gonna be super well tuned
it's not gonna be tuned to make real
music because you've been out there
bashing it for no reason so respect the
music of it you know you know a real man
you know you may want to get you a
little case for your dick it just you
know goes on the front of your dick and
you open it up and it's like got that
kind of blue felt in there like a
saxophone and I'm gonna in grade school
somebody would open that case and I have
the blue felt in there with the sax in
there it a little horn or something a
little trumpet a little still well with
is you know little metal hit or a nap
rap yeah maybe put that around your junk
that way you're gonna treat it like it's
something special because you out there
beating your crotch against the wall for
no reason and then expecting it to
mozart in the bedroom but you have their
Machine Gun Kelly in it at all afternoon
it's not real life button but yeah if
you do have a real problem with to get
ahold of it now man by not getting ahold
of it you know what I'm saying and be
good to yourself dude and stay out the
frickin Park bruh geese man feet what is
going on dude this is Halloween what am
I thinking man am I taking all this
serious and you guys are all messing
with me today the hotline is always is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three that is the hotline you can
always call it and it'll always be here
for you and also if you're a young man
that struggling with something lives in
the Los Angeles area hit us up nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three you know we're trying to solve
some of these problems or some issues
that men are struggling with in real
time and it can be you know something
real something that's going on you know
I don't want you to be afraid to reach
out here that this isn't a safe space
and you can say on the message look you
know I you know just just let us know
what's up and maybe I haven't been
bringing enough from our problems into
the show you know maybe I've been
holding back I think I want to think
about that over the next week you know
Halloween and what skeletons are in your
closet you know is that bone marrow
are you just happy to see me let me tell
you this right here this past weekend is
supported by hellofresh the meal kit
delivery service that shops plans and
delivers your favorite recipe and
pre-measured ingredients so you can just
cook eat and enjoy I've been using
hellofresh again and I forgot how much I
liked it you know if you have somebody
your you have a child or a couple of
children you know if you were if your
son just lost 4 animals this year or
something and you guys need to spend
more time together if you have a spouse
and you need to spend more time together
somebody you're dating or even just a
date you're planning on hellofresh is a
fun thing to do
the recipes right there the ingredients
are right there it's really like
old-fashioned cooking and sometimes you
think oh this isn't like you know this
isn't like a mom's recipe or from
scratch but it's it's it is it's nicely
it's all it's it's just already planned
for you it takes some of the
organization out of it but it takes the
enjoyment and keeps it right there and
available for you there are three plans
to choose from
classic veggie and family each box is
made up of fresh responsibly obtained
ingredients from carefully selected
farms and high rated trusted sources you
can subscribe to enjoy benefits of
hellofresh week after week you can pick
what meals you want online and it comes
in a nice box it's all nice and cold
they got the meats and the veggies and
everything is well taken care of you can
get delicious filling meals delivered
right to your door every week for less
than $10 per serving and free shipping
I'm not just selling you this I wouldn't
sell you something that I don't like I
use this and I enjoy it it's good stuff
hello fresh for $20 off your first three
boxes for a total of $60 off you can
visit hellofresh comm slash Theo 60
that's hellofresh dot-com slash th EO
six zero the number six and the number
zero and inter come in and enter promo
code
Theo 60 that's hello fresh com Theo 60
code Theo 60 for a total of 60
dollars off the Saints and Vikings are
playing tonight and I've recorded it so
I'm here I'm here working doing this
doing this instead and you know I didn't
even think twice about it I'm just happy
to be here you know I've been feeling
like emotionally exhausted like I've
been having a tough time kind of getting
in touch with my own emotions so I'm
gonna try to think of some ma not think
of some ways but I need to take some
actions to make myself um just feel a
little bit more connected you know I
think just life getting busier working
and busier but I don't want to ever get
too busy that I can't be a part of this
podcast in an effective in the most
effective way so I just want to let you
guys know that that's part of my life
right now and I'm so glad that God is
you know where the higher powers or
whatever time the clock you know mother
nature has given us uh what's going on
you know the time of year right now
because this is a great time of year to
bring people together it really really
is all right what else here we go
it was a theory that comes from West
Virginia West by God Virginia and West
Virginia is one of the two virginia's
and i think you guys should fight it out
bro twins come on shut it down one of
you guys that's what we need on we're
brother thanks for calling
how does color save house
listen your keep that k podcast and
whenever you came on there and that
means the fighter in the kid podcast i
was on there the other day i think i
know what you're talking about
let's hear more on Rappaport in full
Rick flair asked meets rock and roll
Express [ __ ] with the belt I just
picture like you coming up with it with
big brown texting and let you know that
graphic words talking smack is coming
hard on yen and then I picture you may
be looking at the belt for inspiration
and perhaps reach into your roots where
tears come from both tears of joy and
tears obscure hell yeah man you're right
in tune brother and just pulling out
that Ric Flair and rock and roll's fresh
me macho man [ __ ] just breaking it out
on him and covered in their heart I came
in there hard boy the Rat King
but you sealed the deal if I had to
spend whatever it takes on line for my
help and promote you to win the [ __ ]
belt back on my hair and talk back but
defend the belt then that's what we'll
do folks don't lie votes don't lie yeah
that was a craziest thing when I went in
there so yeah I was still I was sitting
in here in my studio and I was waiting
for your Raya faber to come in and he's
a you know an accomplished a beautiful
young fighter and he's a fight boy and
he's a fifty boy and he's a great you
know what talented I mean in this guy do
you shake his hand and weighs like 40
pounds a man is uh he's uh he's dense
and he's talented
and he I'm waiting for him to come in
and I hear this yapping going on through
the wall like a chihuahua you know like
a chihuahua that somebody gave to a to a
to an eight-year-old
and I hear that yappin and then I'm
texting over there takes Brandon Brandon
showers I said who do you guys have in
studio and he's like Michael rapport and
then I listen closer and they're talking
about me and that's when the king the
Rat King just comes out of me and it's
just you know it is it's all the things
that it was just all the things all the
people that told me I can't you know
when it's all the people that you know
that a lot that can cry about the voting
and the people that that be that can be
sore losers you know in the people that
they don't want to understand other
people's lives they don't even want to
try to put themselves in other people's
shoes and that's the Rat King
this that forgotten character that
crawls up out of the sewers and says hey
we all deserve a crown you know we all
have something inside of us that is
worried that is worthy of some type of
royalty or the feeling at least once in
a while to feel like being a king
because a lot of us out there that have
nothing you know they don't have any
cheese baby but I'll tell you this man
will come to the surface time and time
again when we smell some stinking them
and that's what I smelled there well
Michael Rapaport calling me out and so I
looked at that belt and next thing you
know son I swear to God I blinked and I
was in my I was I was in my sunglasses
and I was I was Wratten I was writing
down the hall and I rolled right in
there because if you want to talk behind
my back then I'm about to spend my spine
around daddy and now we're face to face
but thank you for calling in and
checking in about that man and that's
what that red is the eternal underdog
and that's what I feel sometimes like
this podcast is man you know we all just
want to be okay and we all just want to
be good people you know when we all just
want to love somebody and be loved and I
think we're in this world right now
we're going through a time as a lot so
many transitions going on in the history
of humanity
right now and we're a young species
human beings you know 2,000 years and
we're only you know or however many
thousand you know I'm just going off a
you know 0 if it's 1997 or whatever it
is right now but you know just a lot of
transitions going on you know people
learning how what our emotions are and
what our feelings are and you know
getting addicted to technology and you
know it's a wild time
it is a wild time but some of us out
there we want to we're still fighting
we're still fighting and learning at the
same time and that's the hard thing to
do I feel like for myself you know I
want to take action and I want to but
I'm also you know a lot of times I live
in fear of being able to say what I
really think sometimes and some of it is
just because I don't feel smart enough I
don't feel like I have enough knowledge
so I don't know when you don't have the
brain sometime you got to let your heart
be your brain and just talk from there
and that's what we do here man with um
underdog aortas baby we're a curious
crew let's take another call here we go
hey Theo where's Pat I'm from enough to
mean a pat thank you for calling from
Augusta Maine you know you have a
beautiful state up there you guys are
often uh I feel like you guys are lucky
in a way you kind of get to you're like
the appendix of America you're you're
you're you're there and you are kind you
know you're constantly you're always
around every now and then you flare up
and raise hell but you also don't have
to be constantly affected by the daily
stuff I bet there's a lot of blessings
to that I've spent some time up there on
isleboro Island out there eating lemon
ices and being natural out there let's
hear more I've lived here my whole life
I'm happiest song and cast American my
parents met during the war oh wow that's
beautiful man do you know what you you
know what has got to be
wild for you then and this is just me I
don't if is judge I'm going to just
guess I don't know what this is but man
that you're a product of a war you know
half Vietcong or have Vietnamese and
half American
yeah man think about that that there's a
war going on and uh and babies and a
baby was made
yes I mean
as as beautiful as sad as that isn't as
wild of a circle that is that is
beautiful you know babies are often the
healing thing of a lot of different
things you know a baby someone has a
family and a baby and next you know the
family's all come together and they all
have one thing that they all love
immediately in common and that's that's
what it's about and when you see that
with different race you see a child
that's black and white you're like oh
well then you know that the family they
both love that child they both love that
child and that's I think where all of it
gets healed a lot of things take time
and a lot of like the cities' issues in
America someone just take time the news
wants to act like we're supposed to have
everything fixed in a [ __ ] day or a
month but the news also is even give a
[ __ ] and they don't do anything to help
they just do stuff to hurt and but when
you see a child that is two different
ethnicities two different cultures
you're like oh that's the solution
that's the solution and it really is
because then you know that there's two
different cultures both loving the same
thing as much as they can and that's the
solution man it's finding an equal point
of love that's really what does bond I
think people anyway I didn't mean to
make this about my thoughts let's hear
more but anyway my wife of 12 years died
tragically last month
and oh man I'm sorry to hear that I'm
sorry bud let's hear more um I never
thought you know I'll never be the same
again I never thought I'd be able to
smile again but uh I asked my friend
Chris at work what do you listen to all
day and he told me seoeon and I love
your podcast yeah the only reason I've
smiled since my wife's death I just
wanted to say thank you this is a
never-ending struggle but you're the
only thing helped me through it and and
I love you man
I keep doing what you're doing and thank
you oh thanks dude
that's sweet of you to say
that's very nice of you to say that
yeah bet your wife
lucky guy sorry I bet your wife was a
lucky lady
man I don't know what to say except
thank you you know it's kind of weird
like uh I don't know sometimes it's like
more about listening so I wish I could
hear more about your wife you know I
wish I could hear more about like you
know maybe ways that you guys like to
laugh or you know if you guys like to
snuggle up at night like how you like to
hug each other or you know maybe if
y'all like you know if you like to watch
the same program or if you you know I'm
sure you probably know like what how she
likes her coffee or how she likes uh you
know if you get to the restaurant early
what to order for her you know I bet
there's a lot of nice little moments and
things that you guys have that are
special
[Music]
yeah and I bet
I bet it's been a real scary new journey
for you and I just hope that you find a
lot of peace and and in that peace I
hope you find you know a lot of
beautiful memories and thoughts and and
even living memories you know memories
that are so alive that they're there are
memories but they're tapping you on the
shoulder all the time they're kind of
hanging on your back like a backpack and
I hope you find a lot of those too
to keep you comfortable thanks for
calling man happy Halloween and maybe
your wife will stop by and visit I know
maybe that's I hope that's not like a
morbid thought and I don't mean it like
that but but it's a magical time of year
you know and I bet she's probably
thinking about you too but I'm glad that
I could help bring a smile at some point
you know and I feel a lot of I think
someone like what I'm feeling even in my
own life is just you know I just want to
be like of service you know I just want
to be able to you know I just want to be
able to like
I don't know it's like you
I grew up and I don't have anything and
then now like I have some stuff and it's
like I don't know there's still the only
thing I want to do is just feel okay
you know the only thing I want to do is
like I don't know I just want to be
associated with stuff that that uh that
helps out so and I bet your wife also is
probably gonna really try and inspire
you to do some neat things in the future
you know she's gonna find a lot of neat
ways probably to live through you and
and that can be a beautiful relationship
I bet you know but I but I'm sure she's
all loving you wherever she is right now
man and I believe that you're gonna see
her again you know in a really really
neat or special place or realm and y'all
might be foxes in the next life what
about that boy and what if maybe I'm in
a little canoe and I come down the river
and I see two Fox is getting kind of
foxy over there on the rocks and I'm
like doing them some rocks Fox is over
there so you never know ma'am be ready
you know I want to start learning how to
be you know dress up like a fox at the
house or you know learning how to run
around on all fours because man your
lady's gonna be looking to be frisky too
if she's ready to see you in that next
realm but I Love You Man happy Halloween
to you let's take another call hey Theo
my name is ELISA I'm 23 from Chicago
Eisen listening to your podcast not for
like six months and I love it thanks
Alicia and I love Chicago you know I
love Illinois Oh word so cathartic and
so funny I do have a question I got this
like guy advice dating advice um just
because I'm seeing this guy right now
he's 28 and he kind of seems like he has
maybe like a similar upbringing as you
in the sense that you didn't have his
dad around and his relationship with his
mom was tumultuous to say the least
and I noticed that as my dating like he
there's days where he's just not talking
to me as much and like he seems so great
the majority of the time but he also
seems like he's having issues like
connecting with me and and being
consistent and sighs don't I mean he
seems like he's interested in me
but at the same time I'm not sure do you
think that this is something I should
bring up to him you think I should have
given the space about talking to him
what was he like with women when we were
28 and do you think that if he's not
being super consistent with me with his
communication that I should just kind of
like stop talking to him or do you think
that I should bring that up to him thank
you for the question thanks for calling
I think I can relate to this some stuff
I can't relate to you know I think you
have to decide what you want for you you
know if you're happy with the points
that you know that it's just kind of a
fun you know if you're happy it's just a
fun time you guys can enjoy each other's
company and and when it when you guys
are connected that it's great thing you
just can rock that and you guys can
enjoy that together if you're looking
for something further you know like more
of them you know marital type of
adventure or do like a honeymoon or
something you know or you know do
marriage or something where you're
together all the time and you got a
fight and stuff and also be in love then
you might want to investigate what's
going on a little bit further I think
trying to be understanding is a good way
to come at it because no matter what's
going on he has an issue and it probably
you know or he there's something do
whatever is there's some behavior he
does that doesn't settle it doesn't you
know that boat doesn't dock correctly
with you so you're like okay well he's
connected for a while and then he's kind
of you know maybe m.i.a or a little
disconnected yeah I can feel that
hundred percent I mean I'm so scared of
that like I just and I'm scared of it
people are like we should just try you
got to give it a shot
I feel you but I mean there's like a
thing in my bones in my body that is
just like I mean that just I turn into a
sasquatch when I think about being
really connected where mom I mean every
part of my being just runs you know like
and I'm not even running it's just
running at its own pace in the Opera at
its own will in the opposite direction
but I'll say this
that
I think just taught you just talking
about it and don't accuse him try and
understand it from his perspective
because here's what's going on with him
is this and it's something I'm still
learning all the time like I yeah I'm
thinking okay well here you got this man
you got this tender guy and he's being
sweet and then sometime he's being you
know missing in action you know he's
like a prisoner warriors and and but
what's up with him so for him he's
connected and then he's not so he's
pulling back a little bit well there
must be some reason maybe he doesn't
want a full connection I think I would
ask him say sometimes I noticed this I'm
fine with it
do you want to talk about it and leave
it there let him you know meet him
halfway and just try to be loving
towards him you know you can be loving
towards him and then also decide whether
or not the relationship is for you you
know and and that's something that's
missing a lot of times in this world and
I'm not saying it's missing with you you
sound like you really care because you
actually call and are thinking about it
but sometimes connectivity is really
hard for people and commitment is hard
and and I don't know then at that point
yeah you'll just have to maybe give it a
chance see what he says and go from
there but but just you can love yourself
and respect yourself and the choice that
you're gonna make and then at the same
time you can also lovingly approach him
with with seeing what's going on with
him so but I appreciate the call I don't
know if that was helpful or not but
that's what I said you know that's all I
had that's all I have to say because I'm
ready for some candy soon because it's
Halloween okay let's take another call
hey Co this is Michael from Iowa hey
Michael the Shire of the United States
dang guy I got a little dark artistry
question for you oh 27 504 and my wife
is a little bit of a hippie and she
wanted to try that placenta on the
second one so we kept the placenta on
the second one
brought it home and we had a nice
blender we had a Vitamix you still have
it
dang dang dude you you drilling up baby
parts and stuff for what what are y'all
gonna do make up um like a moisturizer
or something is this for what what is it
onward ground that up poured it out in
ice cubes
you got those stem-cell hitters dog you
got placenta ice cubes oh my god this is
so slithering bro this ain't no
Hufflepuff cake right here more and swap
those things in this movie everyday I
tried a couple and I don't know it was
you know felt weird but the quad the
questions are three parter number one
does that does that make us cannibals
numb okay is it cannibals if you eaten
part of your own children placenta I
think is how much you have you know
people have called a before about you
know a lot of young guys when they 14
and whatever they busted you know they
bust a new D out and they have it you
know and I'll be honest and it's very
growing up style they have a little dab
of it on their tongue or they put a
little on the back of her mouth you know
get a little wuss you know and that's
doing that's called full circle when you
know you know you know even not eating
but when you haven't even just a little
dab beyond yogurt so if you're eating
placenta [ __ ] ice pops at the house
with your lady dog do y'all got to end
up on the episode of snapped what are
the rest of the questions work to have
you tried I've never had any center bra
I don't do that that baby wrapping paper
brothers dude that's the lord's to-go
box man and I'm not dealing with all
that that's you know that's something
special that's that ninth layer of skin
bruh
that's that's something different man
I'm making you guys next you know you
sitting at the house making wallets out
of that [ __ ] and stuff you got this is
the dark arts this is the dark arts man
Christ more and number three I saved the
forest once but that's uh not to eat
just to [ __ ] around with and I would
like maybe uh some input on what to do
with it like nine months old sit in the
freezer
ha so yeah I don't know yeah dude I
don't know either
don't call me when you guys are hiding
body parts this ain't that kind of place
you know a lot of calls today people
have been sending in all kinds of stuff
a lot of calls today with people you
know running out you know dying animals
and they're blaming it on a
nine-year-old and then you got this guy
him and his wife's making freaking you
know baby wrapping paper smoothies out
here and drinking you know you know
doing suppositories a baby snot and all
of that and hiding the stem cells in
their back door and their booties and
all what is going on dude this is not I
mean look I'm all for trying something
new but I don't know if I could sleep at
night knowing that a little bit of your
babies in the freezer breath I mean I've
tried some stuff at you know my boy
Duncan just sent me a bunch of elk five
pound bucket of elk but I've never done
anything like that you know I've never
put any freaking BP butter that baby's
Cinna butter that plus cz I don't know
Jesus Christ I don't know what else to
say man all right let's take a video
call here that came in you can send him
video calls through the website theof on
comm on the podcast link there there is
a their directions how to submit a video
on word hey Theo this is grant from
Portland Oregon
oh hey grant what's up man thank you for
calling my friend I was just looking for
some advice I'm a foreman at a paving
company and I just started my own paving
company and a lot of the guys that I
work with who've seen me at the first
paving company and I was a shovel ER and
a laborer and it
a hard work but it came to a point where
somebody would say I don't want to do
that and I would say I want to do that
and I'd move up I'd learn new things and
now I'm a foreman and a lot of these
guys have been there longer than me so
they don't really respect me and they
don't really listen to what I say and
I'm just wondering if you've come up
with a way to earn somebody's respect I
mean I work like crazy I bust my ass and
I'm dirty all the time and I practically
have no life and I don't really want to
do that and I also just don't want to be
a dick to these guys it's just wondering
if you had any advice gang gang gang
gang grant thank you for calling man
just listen to here's what I would say
just keep showing up keep showing up
keep showing up you know I got in the
common areas people like god this guy
can't do what he's from this side you
know he's from this background he's from
this he's from that he can't do this job
you know what I keep showing up I show
up when they you know when I got to go
it cost me $500 to fly out to Toledo
want you know and I go show up and I go
to the next club and I go show up and
for 14 years I discuss I show up I show
up I show up and I do my job and I don't
be mean others and you know I pray for
my enemies and I just try and stay you
know and just control what I can control
and and you're gonna have to work hard
man you're gonna have to work hard
because it's not even that you're
proving them wrong as you would you what
you're doing really you're proving you
right and that's the way to look at it
this has nothing to do with them this
just has to do with you because you
can't control what they think or do or
anything like that
all you can control is you man and you
show up and you do it and you don't have
to work with the same guys look man
people always you'll find somebody else
looking for work you can get guys that
will listen to you and you know but
you're gonna have to show up you're
gonna have to work hard that's what you
can have to do and eventually people
will just see you that way and the
reason they'll see you that way is
because that's who you'll be
you know eventually you just become what
you've been doing
whatever it is if you haven't been you
know you could you're becoming a foreman
you're becoming a dancer you're becoming
a someone who you know you know does
magic do for 15 for 10 years the first
10 years to do a magic people think
you're just some [ __ ] crazy person
who accidentally suffocated you know a
few rabbits in a hat but then but damn
boy you [ __ ] Larry Siegfried and ah
you know Jeremy Davenport or whatever
those guys are from Las Vegas as magical
guys so it's just you know you just hit
but they they had to show up and do it
you know a tiger bit one of those guys
but he [ __ ] now he does he doesn't
magic you didn't have a face but he had
done the magic so long he can still do
the magic without a face man and that's
baffling and that's just consistency you
just keep doing it and you show up and
then and and then and you'll be what
you're working towards and you can do it
man I think you got it in you and it's
not and and and if and if something gets
a little test you just say what you mean
but don't say it mean that's what my
brother always says to his children say
what you mean but don't say it mean if
they want to judge or whatever that's
fine
say look I'm just trying my best you
know and every now and then I ask them
for suggestions make them feel a part of
you notice because you have a position
that's higher than somebody doesn't mean
that you as a person are or that you as
somebody that can't be understanding to
them or that can't include them you know
sometimes I'll know something or think I
will and I'll just ask somebody else
anyway
they get to feel like they're helping me
out then it makes them feel good I think
you're gonna manage it just fine man
just be confident in yourself and and
show up you can do it bro
a foreman man congratulations man I
applaud that you know my brother once
had one day was cutting down trees and
he's climbing up there with a damn
chainsaw dude and we don't have real
strong legs so we could barely even hold
onto a tree you know we could barely
even just barely hold onto a tree if it
if a little bit of wind blew we would
fall right off with very weak in her in
her thigh muscles like just like violin
strings man like just [ __ ] flats and
uh and one day he's like dude he cut
into a tree and was full of bees and
next thing you know he's running into
people's houses and they think he's a
burglar and he's not he's just a shitty
chainsaw man running from bees but that
day he decided you know what I don't
need to be the guy with a chainsaw I'm
able to be the guy down at the bottom
directing the guy with the chainsaw and
fast forward eight years and our brother
runs an amazing uh you know he's out
arborist now he's and he's runs an
amazing tree company and it's just
because he decided for himself that one
day he was gonna be that he wasn't
something that he outgrew whatever it
was or that he wanted something else and
at first people said I'm sure this man
he's just uh he's just a chainsaw man
that bothers bees but eventually they'll
see you different and if you just show
up and be different but anyway I saw I
just wanted to think about my brother
for a second so that's why I told you
that we'll take this last call man and
we're gonna get out of here I know
there's been a long episode and that's
Halloween man and and uh and that's what
happens on the holidays we got to enjoy
i'ma stay up with late with each other
and do scary stuff do Jeff over Detroit
man what's up Jeff in Detroit thank you
for calling sir while calling him bro
got some of the DA cards coming up got
my old man
sickness oh wow got that cancer in the
lungs
man I'm sorry to hear that he got that
cancer bra and you know stiff and
falling off and I mean old man he wasn't
it wasn't greatest you know yeah it's
drinking at the [ __ ] my time I was
teenager you know I have my own but come
back to me want to reconnect wants to be
real now for know me I don't want to
come on a thing and got to hate my heart
no more home but don't know if there's
that in this just cuz you're sick I
don't make all the pass no way no make
Nothing go away I don't know man just
sending my thoughts out there the world
doing your people they all go people to
same gang man thank you for your call
wow it says that's a lot you know that's
a lot and that's what life is about man
is uh is is feeling things and you're
right there you know you have a father
he wasn't a big part of your life and
now he has terminal cancer and now he's
coming back to you and wants to connect
you know I realize in my own life that
well look I won't even make this about
me man you know you have
just just because he might not have been
a good father or wasn't capable of being
a good father you know some people
aren't capable they're just not capable
and now you suffer that and in some ways
he probably suffered it too you know I
find it hard to believe that there's not
a deadbeat dad out there who doesn't
think either some when they fall asleep
at night even if they haven't seen him
in a long time and even though you know
like you know he wasn't the best father
you could still be a good son
and that can be in whatever yeah you
know you don't have to make up feelings
of love for him but you can still be a
loving human
you know you can still be a good son and
that defines a lot about you
you know because his definition of where
of you you know he wrote a lot of his
definition to you guys but you haven't
finished writing your definition of you
guys nothing to be able to say you know
to yourself years from now and you were
a good son
you know that you loved your
when he wasn't capable of loving you
SiC now he's the one who maybe need some
help he's the one who's struggling
you're you're kind of the father right
now you know and it's a big sacrifice
because it you know there's gonna be
there would be needs that are deep
inside of you you'll never get met
you'll never get them met
you note about
to the side for now and try and be
loving and just you know I think even
just
in any effort is huge by you because you
have a chance to decide what kind of Sun
you want to be you know and even if you
don't and if you decide not to do
anything then you can still do that too
you know and you and there's no there's
no loss here there's no loss but I'd
hate for you to
I'd hate for you to look back on this in
the future and
and wish that you would
differently
you know cuz it takes a lot to love
somebody that didn't that wronged you or
that didn't you know that you feel like
didn't love you or couldn't express love
to you it takes a lot man but man that's
powerful
powerful you have the ability to change
his heart I think because if you show
him how much how loving you can be he's
gonna realize that there's only one
place that he could that you could have
gotten that ability to love from and
that's from him and from your mother cuz
y'all you notice that's your your them a
man that's gonna be powerful when that
resonates in his heart that he's able to
create something like a love that much
it's gonna make him realize that he
could have loved that much you know and
maybe that'll be the little the
unlocking of the chasm that shows him
that he can you know but I'm sorry to
hear that about your father and I wish
you love and look bruh
onward man in some way shape or form we
got to move homeward it's that time of
year you know you can take something
that's been haunting you for a while you
can put a new lighting and put a new
little light in
he can start a new adventure with an old
pumpkin
anything can happen man it's that time
of year keep your chakras open you can
do it be good to yourself he probably
deserved it man I I'm gonna take us out
here with the song that brought us in
Vampires Suck by John Bjork
happy Halloween man I love you guys yeah
[Music]
you